I don't think he runs again I can't see
it I don't see it hey guys I'm off the
grid for August but little-known
podcaster Joe Rogan just did something
that's culturally relevant one more year
from now there's no way how Newsome is
coming up and trying to run
um there are other people that are
circling I don't think he runs again I
can't see it I don't see it how do you
think they get Kamala Harris a step down
because she's rightfully if he steps
down you know until some if Kamala
Harris cannot say a sentence it's almost
she's almost worse than him she talks in
like Gypsy curses
when they ask her something she'll be
like my grandma said that a half of bees
is still bees if you if you bury it and
you're like what
that's how she speaks the woman is uh it
has no idea what's going on